as drought conditions worsen across the
valley many have reached out to us
questioning watering schedules at local
parks sally jaramillo is live near d-i
and decatur with how they operate in the
efforts to conserve sally
kirsten many of our channel a viewers
have reached out to us asking us if
parks have to also follow the same
watering schedule
as home buyers now the answer is yes but
depending on the specific park those
schedules could change
i visit local parks almost every weekend
i bring my daughter and her friends to
parks on the west side sometimes in
north summerlin or even up in north las
vegas courtney kreisberg is a mother who
lives on the west side part of the
valley she has lived here for over 20
years and says right now it is very
important for all las vegas and all
nevada residents to conserve water and
when it comes to community parks
spokesperson for the las vegas valley
water district bronson mack says parks
are permitted to submit a designation as
a community used recreational turf area
under that designation if approved they
are permitted to have an alternative
watering schedule parks are following a
watering schedule to help ensure that
they're doing exactly what residents are
doing max says the parks here are
extremely responsive we've replaced many
of our sports fields with artificial
turf senior manager analyst for the city
of las vegas marco vilada says at this
point last year they had reduced 100
million gallons of water which is about
eight percent over the previous fiscal
year we want to continue to make those
conservation measures and do things to
reduce our overall uh consumptive use
try to cut back on your water usage when
you can because the future of las vegas
depends on it
back out live if you discover water
being wasted at a park now contact the
specific municipality or you can simply
report it online for now reporting live
sally caramillo live local now